a lot of the time it can be really fun
to watch a terrible movie
especially when it's so bad that it's
actually kind of good
some movies however are so bad they're
just about unwatchable
case in point take a look at these
irredeemable flops after the release of
his stunning holocaust dramatic comedy
life is beautiful
roberto benini was the toast of italian
cinema
that movie took home three oscars and
made millions of dollars at the box
office in 1998
which might just explain why he was
given the okay to film a live
action version of pinocchio but it
doesn't even come close to explaining
the movie he
actually made indeed benini's remake was
an
all-out cinematic disaster the reviews
were brutal
the box office returns were worse and in
a matter of days
benini's career in hollywood was pretty
much finished
but this story does at least have kind
of a happy ending as benini went on to
play gepetto in the 2019 italian
adaptation of the classic tale
which performed far better with both
critics and audiences
the 2002 action flick ballistic x versus
sever was arguably the first
high-profile
zero percent whiff in rotten tomatoes
thin four-year history
and rightfully so even today it's hard
to imagine how a studio actually spent
70 million dollars on a convoluted
far-fetched spy thriller starring
antonio banderas and lucy liu
either way all that money didn't fool
critics more than 100 of them panned the
movie
landing it quickly in worst movie ever
territory
it's remained there ever since the
original highlander is a compelling
contender for the most enjoyable movie
ever made
a perfectly tuned epic of 80s cheese
queen music
and sword fights its sequel however is
its polar opposite
think of it like the cinematic
equivalent of a stage performer
accomplishing an incredible magic trick
and then
immediately falling down a trapdoor
there can be only one
right from the bizarre sci-fi themed
intro cards it's clear that something
went very wrong during the conception of
the sequel
for this movie the genuinely intriguing
concept of a group of immortals walking
the planet since the dawn of time has
been twisted into limp speculative
fiction about earth's future
even worse the immortals are revealed
not to be an offshoot of humanity but
rather a race of aliens from the desert
planet zeiss
directly contradicting the original's
entire mythology
within the first 10 minutes the result
is a movie that pleases nobody
a betrayal for loyal fans that's still
too weird for newcomers
within days of its limited theatrical
release the john travolta-led
john gotti biopic gotti was being
confidently hailed as the worst mob
movie of all time
while it's hard to be 100 certain if
that's actually the case
it's hard to see how things could get
much worse gotti's greatest sin
is that it's incredibly boring aside
from a few moments of unintended
hilarity there's just not that much to
enjoy bizarrely edited it incredibly
difficult to follow the movie is
essentially
a long collection of technically
uninteresting scenes stitched together
with voice over and real life
archival news footage into something
that only sometimes looks like a film
if gotti ends up being remembered at all
it will likely be due only to the
movie's pugilistic and manipulative
marketing tactics
in an effort to combat its zero percent
favorability among critics producers of
the film rolled out an ad campaign
spuriously claiming that it's not a
movie for critics at all but rather
something the general public would enjoy
and that's fair if you generally don't
think about movies
talk about movies or watch movies then
sure you might be tricked into believing
this movie is fine
as for everybody else stay far away
capisce
here's the thing about rotten tomatoes
movies that acquire a zero percent fresh
rating
aren't necessarily the worst movies in
the world they're all bad to some extent
but they can just as easily be
aggressively average too
stratton is one such movie boring and
uninspired sure
but hey it's probably not going to kill
anybody either coming from the director
of conair and the expendables 2
stratton is a by the numbers action
movie that never manages to elevate
itself in the way those semi-respectable
adventures did
the movie follows a government agency's
quest to stop a rogue former soviet
operative
from launching a chemical weapon attack
on london and if that plot line sounds
derivative
that's because it is and you'd better
get used to it because there's not an
original bone in this movie's body
stratton's cardinal sin however is that
it brings together all those cliches and
tired tropes but forgets to throw in
any actual tension or excitement and you
kinda need those in an action movie
so sure stratton may not be the worst
movie ever made but you'd still be
hard-pressed to find a single good
reason to watch it
eli roth's 2002 horror flick cabin fever
is far more notable for kicking off the
filmmaker's career than it is for its
actual merits as a movie mostly because
it has so few somewhat obnoxious gory
and sporadically entertaining
it's the sort of middling movie that
could have really benefited from the
remake treatment
with another artist pulling out its best
assets while discarding the material
that just doesn't work
but that's not what happened instead the
2016 version of the movie is essentially
the same film
just with worse acting worse casting and
even lower production values
virtually every one of cabin fever's
reviews zeroed in on its utter
pointlessness
critiquing the movie on a fundamental
level and questioning its very reason to
exist
in a vacuum this tale of a bunch of
pretty young people getting
absolutely wrecked by a flesh-eating
virus probably wouldn't have warranted
such disdain
but considering the movie's other
crippling flaws it's pretty hard to know
for sure
is there a movie star on earth more
obviously bored with his career than
bruce willis
once the very embodiment of the
charismatic everyman willis most recent
achievements
seem to have amounted to little more
than tanking the die hard franchise and
refusing to appear in the expendables 3
but while willis's more recent projects
haven't exactly been great
it's rare that his movies get as
devastatingly dull as
2016's precious cargo writing for roger
ebert dot com
the critic peter sabsinski described his
action movie as a vod craptacular
that is basically as forgettable as they
come it's a film
completely incapable of transporting the
viewer into its world
leaving you constantly aware that you're
watching actors who are simply going
through the motions
they drive speed boats they shoot guns
they collect paychecks there's no
artistry here
you know it the filmmakers know it and
bruce willis clearly knows it more than
anyone
if he had just played up to the movie's
badness nick cagedow
willis might have been able to make
precious cargo just a little more
entertaining
instead he looks annoyed to even have to
be there still
in that sense at least it's probably his
most relatable performance in years
unfortunately simon says isn't a movie
adaptation of the hit light up game
although
even watching a simon toy light up for
an hour and a half would probably be
more entertaining than this dire dennis
rodman sequel
the original movie double team featured
the bad boy basketball player and
jean-claude van damme
teaming up to kick butt and act badly
yes
behind you
vandam didn't return for the sequel
however so they got the next best thing
dane cook as such the movie is filled to
the brim with so-called comedy
alongside a bunch of shots of rodman
trying to look cool while things blow up
in the background
so yeah it's bad but it at least serves
as an amusing reminder that dennis
rodman
actually used to be a pretty big deal a
long
long time ago if you watched the fourth
season of project greenlight
the leisure class may as well have been
called shot and freud the movie
in the reality show about a contest
winner getting a chance to make their
own film
ben affleck and matt damon picked the
supremely obnoxious jason mann as their
champion
the leisure class was the result a
comedy where nothing funny happens
the characters inexplicably change on a
whim and even the basic story
doesn't really make any sense on the
surface it's a good idea for a film
a con man falls in love with his mark
only to have his near do well brother
come in at the last minute to mess
everything up
but the tone changes wildly from scene
to scene the lead is shockingly stiff
and it even
looks horrible it's truly hard to find
anything good about the leisure class
which is why it's so delightful to watch
seeing an arrogant kid like man get his
comeuppance in more or less real time
is more satisfying than you can possibly
imagine
when the sitcom friends became a hit for
nbc in 1994
hollywood quickly signed up at six young
and funny cast members to headline a
number of future films
for the most part these movies were
forgettable middling romantic comedies
like david schwimmer's the pallbearer or
matthew perry's fool's rush in
these movies were nothing special but
they weren't exactly horrible either
and then there's ed the 1996 sports
comedy starring matt leblanc
opposite a rowdy chimpanzee leblanc
plays jack deuce cooper
a talented baseball pitcher who chokes
under pressure so much
that he's relegated to an obscure minor
league team even more humiliating
the team's third baseman is its former
mascot a primate named ed
over the course of the movie deuce
learns to believe in himself and how to
be a good friend all because of that
wacky chimp with a heart of gold
not only was ed a box office bomb
bringing in a grand total of 4.4 million
dollars
but critics were united in their utter
hatred for the movie
for example dason thompson of the
washington post called it
breathtakingly unadventurous with its
cheesy storyline
hackneyed ballpark fable sentiments
adorable animal
and collection of one-dimensional human
nincompoops
in the early 1980s chuck norris was the
king of a certain kind of patriotic war
movie
in which the star could bomb shoot and
karate kick bad guys to his heart's
content
the success of missing in action in the
delta force would eventually lead to
norris playing a mystical kick happy
lawman
on the 90s action show walker texas
ranger this thing led to a revival of
his film career which by then had taken
a bit of a downward turn
this was largely because norris's style
of movie had grown a little passe
so filmmakers tried to open things up by
sticking him in a family comedy
the result is top dog in which norris
plays a loose cannon cop who gets teamed
up with a super smart police canine
top dog is supposed to appeal to kids
but it's also casually and extremely
violent
following a plot about extremist terror
attacks critics loathed the movie too
which wound up with a zero percent on
rotten tomatoes as roger ebert asked in
his chicago sun times review
why exactly would you want to make a
movie about racist hate groups and then
disguise it as family entertainment
about a cute dog
launch to stardom in the late 1980s with
the movie i'm gonna get you sucker and
then in the 90s with the sketch comedy
series in living color
filmmaker and actor keenan ivory wayne
struggled to find a follow-up project
that was a good match for his talents
his two stabs at action heroism most
wanted and the glimmerman
both bombed but at least critics had a
few nice things to say about those
movies
the same can't be said for wayne's 1994
romantic action comedy a low down dirty
shame
wayne's wrote and directed the oddly
laid back movie about andre shane
a disgraced police detective in private
eye who just can't seem to bust drug
kingpin mendoza
suddenly shane finds a new lead and gets
back on the case with the help of his
sassy assistant peaches
austin chronicle critic alison macor
summed up the movie best writing
i'm not sure what type of movie this is
supposed to be or who its audience is
but it's a low down dirty shame that
wayan's talent is wasted on this film
some of the movies that have tried and
failed to reach the critical and box
office highs of the original jaws
include deep blue sea the mini sharknado
movies
and jaws own sequels you're gonna need a
bigger boat
making a movie like this is like walking
a tightrope over a proverbial shark tank
if it's too violent salacious or gory
then it's an outright bad movie
if it goes too far in the other
direction instead focusing on tension
and dread then it's usually perceived as
little more than a jaw's rip-off
somehow dark tide manages to be both
halle berry plays a shark expert and
diving teacher who has to guide a
daredevil rich guy
into a part of the ocean so infested
with sharks that it's nicknamed
shark alley you can probably guess what
happens next
as peter bradshaw wrote in the guardian
the sharks themselves are the only ones
to emerge with credit from this
hollywood foisted seven police academy
movies onto the world in the 80s and 90s
despite
only the first being a true blockbuster
and all of them getting
absolutely savage by the critics as far
as rotten tomato scores are concerned
police academy is among the most
critically loathed and poorly reviewed
franchises in movie history
entries four through seven citizens on
patrol assignment miami beach
city under siege and mission to moscow
are all rated at zero percent on the
site
operating under the premise that a big
city police department has to sign up
virtually anyone who wishes to protect
and serve
these particular installments find the
cadets training new hires
traveling to miami fighting an organized
crime ring and trying to take down a
money launderer in moscow
ian freer of empire in his review of
police academy 4
citizens on patrol summed up the
thoughts of his fellow critics with
regards to the whole series
he wrote oh dear oh dear oh dear
tom selleck got his movie career going
in 1987 with the smash hit
three men and a baby sadly he didn't
have many more hits beyond that
although he did offer up a kind of
reversal on three men and a baby with
the 1992 comedy
folks in which he played a yuppie trying
to contend with his aging parents
supposedly a comedy folks is basically a
nasty 100 minute insult against
well-meaning elderly people
select plays jon who invites his
increasingly infirm parents to move in
with him and his family after his father
burns down their home however
his folks meddling somehow causes
celic's character to lose his job
as well as his wife and kids in his
review for the seattle times
michael upchurch wrote the film's appeal
will depend largely on whether you feel
like laughing at see now dementia
and that about sums it up the d-grade
e.t rip-off mac and me
is noteworthy for just a few reasons
firstly it contains perhaps the most
egregious use of product placement in
hollywood history with an entire scene
being devoted to an amazing birthday
party held at mcdonald's
that even features ronald mcdonald
himself it's also a dance number
which e.t is notably lacking so at least
mcamee brought something new to the
table
but that's about it honestly the only
real reason anyone might have to watch
this silly 80s flick is to get some
context for a running gag
paul rudd has been doing for years every
time he guests on conan o'brien's show
to promote a film
he switches out the clip of that film
with the same clip from mac and me
[Music]
he's been doing it for over 10 years now
and to his credit it's actually a pretty
good bit which is more than can be said
for the movie itself
stories about secret government
conspiracies were a big deal in the 90s
unfortunately for every all-time great
like x-files or enemy of the state
you had well you had something like
shadow conspiracy
charlie sheen at the time a legitimate
movie star after the success of platoon
and hot shots
stars as bobby bishop an innocent and
earnest presidential aide
who discovers a plot orchestrated by the
white house chief of staff
to assassinate the commander-in-chief
people get killed left and right as a
result
and it's up to bobby and a plucky
reporter to put an end to the threat
from within
the problem is shadow conspiracy isn't
quite as clever as it thinks it is
according to maitland mcdonough of tv
guide corpses pile up
dreadful secrets are uncovered and
bishop eventually gets to the bottom of
things
a full hour after the least attentive
viewer will have figured out who's
behind it all
in elementary school millions of
american kids learn about the country's
homegrown folklore
19th century tall tales about
larger-than-life figures like the
lumberjack giant paul bunyan
and john henry in the tales henry is a
hulk-like ultra-strong railroad worker
known as the steel driving man the 2020
movie john henry however reimagines the
character as a tough modern day man who
uses his abilities to reluctantly right
wrongs
terry crews plays the titular john henry
who is trying to get over his violent
past when he runs afoul of his old crime
boss after helping two honduran
immigrants escape gang violence
movie critics weren't exactly moved by
john henry however collectively
bestowing it with a zero percent on
rotten tomatoes
jeanette katsulus of the new york times
said no kindness goes unpunished in john
henry
a thug life thriller so frequently
preposterous that it almost resembles a
parody
while michael retrofon of the los
angeles times said john henry lands with
all the subtlety of the mighty still
driving man sledgehammer
flash fancy cars driven by a rogue's
gallery of cocky tight-knit characters
in a world of underground street racing
those are the elements that help make
the fast and the furious franchise
so irresistible and lucrative to
audiences around the world
obviously the filmmakers behind redline
hoped the market was big enough for
another movie of that ilk
only with less money and fewer famous
cast members
unfortunately redline grossed the
poultry 8.2 million dollars
largely because the vast majority of the
movie going public
immediately recognized it for what it
was a shameless
unabashed not very good rip-off of the
fast and the furious saga
not convinced check out this atrocious
scene
[Music]
okay we pulled a rut but critics loathe
the real movie
which currently sits at an impressive
zero percent on rotten tomatoes
as j.r jones of the chicago reader so
succinctly explains
the whole thing is pretty stupid there
are a lot of haunted house movies out
there
to say the least it's a tried and true
film sub-genre
and they really do feel a niche mostly
because audiences love the familiar
beats of stories about things that go
bump in the night
now movie critics traditionally aren't
all that keen on horror movies
but it's still pretty hard to make one
so bad that it's panned by
literally everybody but that's exactly
what happened with the disappointments
room
in this movie a woman named dana and her
family move out of busy brooklyn
in favor of a house in the country it's
already occupied however
by secrets ghosts and plenty of
foreboding dread
all thanks to the family that lived
there in the 1800s
robert beale of the rap said the movie
consists of a litany of embarrassments
while mark savlov of the austin
chronicle wrote that the disappointments
room
lives and dies up to its name
conventional wisdom holds that there are
two kinds of successful movies
box office smashes and critical darlings
there actually isn't a lot of disparity
between the two
blockbusters are often praised by
critics while award winners can get a
serious financial boost from their
plotters
and the movies that critics hate often
bomb at the box office too
after all a dud is a dud but then
there's problem child
a chaotic cynical snotty and somehow
also sentimental comedy with a zero
percent rotten tomatoes
that made an absolute fortune at the box
office
john ritter a beloved tv star who
couldn't really get a legitimate movie
career going plays sweet ben
a man desperate to be a father but
unable to have one biologically
so he adopts junior an almost
demonically bratty kid
who makes life horrible for ben as
dennis king of the tulsa world wrote
it's misguided it's not funny and in its
lame efforts to be irreverent in hip
it turns out to be just plain mean
as noted earlier bruce willis made a
name for himself playing tough guys and
reluctant heroes in action movies during
the 1980s and 1990s a golden age for the
genre
it's been a long time since the release
of die harder armageddon however
and film goers have mostly moved on to
other things but for a small but devoted
audience who still wants to see the
60-something action icon do his thing
he still makes a few low budget action
flicks each year all of which get
quietly dumped onto home video and
streaming platforms
hard kill is an especially bad example
of these late period willis movies
the story of hired guns trying to stop a
supervillain from using computers to
cause worldwide chaos
filming on this movie took place over
just 10 days if nothing else however
that means hardkill managed to earn its
zero percent rotten tomato score with
the utmost efficiency
london fields actually starts out with
an intriguing premise
a psychic named nicola 6 predicts that
she is about to be killed
her sixth sense tells her that her
killer will be one of three men so she
starts an affair with each in order to
discover the true circumstances of her
death
london fields is based on a darkly comic
critically acclaimed 1989 novel by
british mystery author
martin amos but the adaptation
apparently failed to capture what was so
special about the book
peter sobsinski of robert ebert.com said
that even viewers who know the novel
well will have a hard time following the
convoluted action of what amounts to a
boring and garish mess
david sexton of the london evening
standard meanwhile likened london fields
to a music video
while jeanette kat solis of the new york
times found it horrendous
a trashy torch and misfire from
beginning to end still
it could have been worse
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the best and worst movies are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one